chris harrison will not be hosting the
new season of bachelor in paradise
a source tells e.t that the longtime
bachelor franchise host
won't be returning to the reality show
amid his ongoing controversy which
started in march following an interview
harrison did with rachel lindsay
where he appeared to defend rachel
kirkanelle's past racist actions
the picture was from 2018
at an old south antebellum party so i
think it's not a good one no
it's not a good well rachel is it a good
look in 2018 or is it not a good look in
2021
back to paradise the source says there
will be multiple celebrity guest hosts
filling in for harrison in the upcoming
season
david spade being one of them the source
adds that there's speculation that other
comedians might guest host as well
et has reached out to harrison spade and
abc reps for comment
sources told page six who was first to
report the news that spade was chosen as
a guest host because he is a bachelor
superfan
and has quote built a cult following
among fellow fans because of his
hilarious commentary about the show on
instagram
back in march warner horizon and abc
entertainment confirmed to et
that harrison wouldn't be hosting the
new season of the bachelorette former
bachelorettes
tasha adams and caitlyn bristow are
taking over as host for katie thurston
season which premieres june 7th
e.t spoke with adams in may she dished
on getting the call to step
in i was shocked of course i was shocked
this is a very unprecedented time
the former bachelorette also teased what
fans could expect in the upcoming season
caitlyn and i really
just created this really fun dynamic duo
that
has never been done before with the
bachelorette and i feel like it really
provided
a lot of i don't know strength behind
katy and confidence as well because
you're in that situation and sometimes
you don't know what to do
and we were able to provide a little bit
of clarity and help for her of course
this all comes after harrison announced
that he would be taking a step back from
the franchise
after his controversial comments and
during a virtual appearance on good
morning america
in march harrison admitted he quote made
a mistake
i am an imperfect man i made a mistake
and i own that i believe that mistake
doesn't
reflect who i am or what i stand for
i am committed to the progress not just
for myself
also for the franchise he also expressed
his hope to someday return to the
franchise
i plan to be back and i want to be back
this interview
is not the finish line there is much
more work to be done
and i am excited to be a part of that
[Music]
change
you